si pones 10 para ti yo a esta hora me
encuentro regular las principales
autopistas que no sólo conecta a los
sexos del norte y sur de la ciudad sino
también el ingreso y la salida de la
ciudad capital y es aquí donde
precisamente este tipo de autopistas
también están recibiendo bloqueos y
manifestaciones por parte de personas y
autoconvocados que llegan y bloquean las
principales vías de la ciudad capital
inclusive la noche de ayer tuvo un
fuerte volteo y esta autopista y la
mañana de hoy también apareció con
fuertes bloqueo pero qué está pasando lo
que se bloquean las principales
autopistas se produce lo que está
sucediendo en este momento no sólo que
en la ciudad en la sierra sino también
en la costa ecuatoriana que no llega a
los principales tres distribuidores y
camiones
productos a las ciudades y está pasando
que se incrementa el costo de los
productos recordemos que los movimientos
indígenas son principalmente productores
de la tierra y son los que abastecen de
frutas verduras y principales alimentos
a las distintas ciudades no solo la
ciudad capital sino también a las
ciudades de la costa y se siente en este
momento un incremento de los principales
rubros más allá de las cadenas de
supermercados sin principio él también
se siente un desabastecimiento por lo
menos del gas del uso doméstico y
distintos rubros que empiezan a escasear
producto de estas manifestaciones pero
cuál es el estatus de este momento de
las manifestaciones por el presidente de
la republica reaccionó la noche de ayer
donde hace un llamado al diálogo a los
movimientos indígenas pero también dice
que está preparado en el estudio
nacional para enfrentar con él el uso
progresivo de la fuerza en este sentido
también los movimientos indígenas le
respondieron que no llegarán a ningún
diálogo hasta no tener una respuesta a
sus peticiones ya y convocado en 48
horas
ceder a las principales ciudades han
dicho que ingresarán a velocidades de
quito por el cual se espera que este
tipo de días también pasen por aquí con
movimientos indígenas santiago